well the war in Syria is spilling beyond
its borders and raising tensions between
Israel and Iran an Israeli fighter jet
went down in Israel this weekend after
coming under heavy anti-aircraft fire
the plane was involved in airstrikes on
Iranian targets inside Syria Seth Doane
is in hard Diouf Israel at the site of
the crash
Seth good morning good morning this is
where that Israeli f-16 crashed the
pilots ejected and survived but it was
the first time in Israeli military jet
had been shot out of the sky since the
early 1980s and shockingly it was struck
down inside Israeli airspace by a Syrian
anti-aircraft missile a military
intelligence chief we spoke with today
said he worries this could be the start
of a new phase in this war that has
ground on for seven years in Syria one
where we see a direct confrontation
between Iran and Israel over the weekend
Israel saw what had long worried about
Iran allegedly using a base from inside
Syria to launch a drone into Israeli
territory Israeli shot the drone out of
the sky once it entered Israel's
territory and then launched f-16s in
retaliation to target both Syrian and
Iranian positions inside Syria then it
appears Russian President Vladimir Putin
stepped in to try to calm things down
the Russians would like to see this war
come to a close and not enter a new
phase in escalate John Seth Doane in
northern Israel thanks